[Musique]
pour evelyne et là bonjour bonjour vous
êtes candidate pour les élections
municipales candidate à ducos
qu'est ce qui a nourri cette volonté de
vouloir être merde ducos aurait dîné là
alors qu'on le rappelle vous êtes déjà
conseillère territoriale
oui effectivement je suis conseiller
territorial conseillère exécutive et à
la ctm
cela m'a permis d'acquérir une certaine
expérience aujourd'hui je brigue le
poste de maire mais en de ma commune
commune de ducos une commune que j'aime
une commune que les personnes qui
m'entourent aussi ont à coeur de servir
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
aujourd'hui candidate tête de liste
aussi parce que la population c'est vrai
à une certaine attente et je le vois
lorsque j'organise mes réunions de
proximité il y à une affluence assez
conséquente plus d'une centaine de
personnes en tout cas sur les premières
réunions que nous avons eues à réaliser
et je pense que cela traduit un besoin
de la population qui a à coeur de voir
un nouveau souffle pour la ville et
c'est l'occasion puisque le maire jean
landry mance et a choisi de ne pas se
représenter
alors si vous deviez être élu
cela signifie que forcément vous allez
devoir quitter votre fonction votre
mandat plutôt de de conseillère
exécutive
non oui je vais quitter mon mandat de
six ans je vais quitter mon mandat de
conseillère à la ctm pour me consacrer
pleinement à la ville parce qu'il y a
des choses à faire parce qu'il ya un
potentiel aussi à à explorer du coup
c'est vraiment une ville pleine d'atouts
on a une position géographique qui est
centrale on a un tissu socio-économique
qui est dense nous avons vraiment delà
de la matière on a des atouts aussi
naturel qui ne sont pas encore tout à
fait explorer notamment du point de vue
touristique et donc nous avons un
certain nombre de chantiers à mener et
pour cela je crois que la population
aura vraiment besoin d'élus de terrain
et d'élus vraiment engagé et c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs ma liste
appel du causse s'engage alors une fois
arrivé
en mairie si vous étiez élu quel serait
le premier dossier auquel vous
souhaiteriez vous vous attaquez c'est
quoi le dossier prioritaire du point de
vue de la municipalité
du point de vue de la municipalité vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir qu'il y ait un
rapport de la chambre régionale des
comptes qui pointe une situation de
gestion assez difficile une
préoccupation aussi pour le personnel
municipal
donc le premier chantier sera de
rencontrer effectivement ce personnel
les représentants du personnel qui ont
vraiment un besoin de transparence sur
la situation de la ville et les derniers
mouvements le démontre et puis bien sûr
résorber progressivement la situation
qui est celle de la ville de ducos
aujourd'hui et pour cela il y a une
stratégie
qu'est ce qui a provoqué cette situation
selon vous c'est des erreurs de l'équipe
en place où c'est le contexte général
qui concerne finalement la plupart de
nos villes alors toutes les communes
toutes les communes sont confrontées à
des difficultés en entend tous les jours
l'état se désengage d'une certaine
manière les responsabilités et les
compétences sont de plus en plus accrue
pour les communes et notamment pour les
intercommunalités
donc c'est difficile pour du cos ça
l'est d'autant plus qu'il y a eu parfois
des choix de gestion qui ont compliqué
la situation mais ses choix il faut
aujourd'hui les assumer parce qu'on va
en hériter et donc on va partir de
l'existant et on va optimiser en
partenariat avec les partenaires sociaux
que sont les salariés
et puis l'intercommunalité et la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
qui sera aussi sollicitée de fait
voilà alors la ville de ducos qui a une
situation particulière qui est un peu la
porte d'entrée du grand sud
on va dire mais qui est pas si loin que
ça finalement du centre aussi
il ya d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent dans le centre qui habite à
ducos 1 par exemple
donc voilà façon d'introduire cette
question savoir quel est l'enjeu
finalement fondamentale qui va se jouer
en mars 2020 pour justement cette cette
ville cette commune un peu particulière
avec ce que je viens d'écrire tout à
l'heure c'est vrai que c'est une commune
un peu particulière c'est à la fois une
commune urbaine et rurale
donc il ya vraiment un équilibre à
trouver notamment du point de vue de
l'aménagement du territoire comment
accueillir une population qui est de
plus en plus nombreuses à vouloir
habiter à ducos donc on a une commune
qui est attractive les ressources n'ont
pas diminué
donc il y as matière aussi à travailler
simplement ce sera une question
d'organisation de redéploiement une
question d'harmonisation et d' équilibre
à trouver
à tous les points de vue un on parlait
de la gestion du personnel mais c'est
aussi vrai pour l'aménagement du
territoire c'est aussi vrai pour la
population qui a vraiment à coeur
d'avoir un service public de qualité et
avec la le personnel municipal
nous allons engager un gros travail pour
voir dans quelle mesure nous pouvons
apporter des réponses concrètes à la
population de la petite enfance aux
personnes âgées parce que du cos c'est
aussi ça la légende en quelques mots
c'est une frange de la population
diverse donc il faudra aussi accompagner
et c'est le défi à relever on n'a pas
parler d'intercommunalité nous n'avons
pas pour une autre occasion nous aurons
d'autres occasions
j'espère bien parce que ça c'était comme
ça et l'accent mis nu il ya vraiment des
choses à dire merci aurait dîné la même
journée une bonne journée à vous tous
[Musique]